I think the impulse to work with recycled materials...
...started, growing up in a lower-class Canadian family.
Part of my impulse is that the materials I was handed as a child...
...were already used...
...and I like that patina that something acquires over time...
...that it becomes filled with sort of the gravitas, the dignitas,...
...the evidence of its life.
And so, what I try to do now is honor that patina that things collect.
It's both respecting the fact that we're outgrowing the world.
We're using up expendable resources and everybody should be encouraged...
...to open their eyes and become aware of the vast potential...
...that's in the everyday things we have around us.
I think using things and awakening people's aesthetic...
...to the fact that you can reuse, repurpose, redesign,...
...reapply a lot of the things that we normally,...
...that go into the trash recycling chain as art supplies,...
...is a bit of a payback to everything I've been given...
...as material benefit in this world.